Come on Harper I need to finish teaching you how to use the equipment.
That's your job. I'm just here for the astrological benefits.
That's not a thing
Just hurry up. We need to get moving and we're going to miss the meteor shower.
Dude, chill.
Come on. You're gonna get left behind.
Shoot, was that you?
Does it look like it was me?
It was probably just a bug bite or something.
Careful.
Are you guys going in there?
Uhhh yeah, why?
Don't stay too long after dark and don't stray from the trail.
Skinwalkers will come for you.
You mean like ghosts?!
Skinwalkers!
They roam here.
Right well, we're in a hurry, but thanks for the warning...
If you draw a circle with arrows pointing inwards--
We'll keep that in mind. Thanks for the advice, but we really need to go.
Take this!
Just in case.
Thank you!
HARPER: Is this the right way?
RILEY: Look.
It should be here.
Riley?
Riley...?
Riley!!?
Oh my gosh....
Riley...
Thank you for watching Skinwalker. If you enjoyed this film, please give this video a like.
Also, let me know in the comments
what legends you'd like to see us cover in future videos. A lot of weird stuff happened during the production of this film.
Eventually I'm going to do a True Fear episode
documenting it, and when I do I'll drop you a link right here. Until then check out my other horror films it this playlists and
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring that death bell for notifications, and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.